from a group of cutthroat rule-bending
when it all costs egomaniacs who played
politics to a group of you know all
those same things who play football a
report commissioned by the NFL says
patriot quarterback and cover boy Tom
Brady was quote at least generally aware
end quote that a couple of the guys
working for his team were more likely
than not deliberately delayed deflating
footballs before the AFC title game no
one is surprised and neither we guess as
President Obama who hosted the Pats at
the White House two weeks ago I usually
tell a bunch of jokes of these events
but with Patriots in town I was worried
that 11 out of 12 of them would fall
flat mark I have two questions for you
one the first question on a scale of one
to Godzilla how surprised are you by
this revelation and to more importantly
should the Patriots now be forced
compelled to give back the Vince
Lombardi Trophy I'm not that surprised
so I would say on a scale of one to gun
Zilla kami is negative five
look I I get to keep the trophy because
the league let him get away with this
all the other teams were silent it's too
late to take it back but it's ridiculous
and in a league that's got some
credibility problems they should have
stepped in at the time now it's too late
I think you know obviously they will not
be compelled to give the trophy back but
it is the case should they be but then
it is the case though that this Super
Bowl victory will always be tainted
because there will always be a question
that's and that AFC title game was close
there's nobody knows when it affected
but everyone will always think of this
is the Super Bowl that the cheaters won
and it will never be seen as son of New
England I can say you whatever we don't
care we won I mean the Patriots you know
they cheated better than the other teams
and the league should be ashamed for not
punishing them at the time this
investigation could have taken two
minutes this and I look forward to
hearing what tom brady has to say about
it but they want and they'll keep it and
they should I think I can tell you this
is a sub blight on Tom Brady's
reputation and another blight on gold
dollar checks follow the end League's
fall